bonsoir oui donc
à sonner ses mouvements père
elle est
je vais je vais l'amener sur le sur une
recherche commun depuis longtemps parce
que puisqu'on considère vraiment
l'architecturé la ville comme des formes
mouvement et c'est presque antinomique
avec l'idée même l' architecture qui est
là pour être bâtie pour rester pour
quelque part perdurer donc avant de
avant de rentrer dans trois exemples ils
sont trois de nos dernières expériences
j'aimerais partager avec vous une sorte
de credo et qui dit dorénavant par
l'architecturé de la ville ont fait des
idées deux choses différentes
premièrement la ville bête à simuler un
grand dam des fans actifs acte une
oeuvre d'ingénierie et d'architecturé
plus ou moins graves plus ou moins
complexes et qui croît au fil du temps
deuxièmement nous pouvons nous référer à
certains aspects plus limité mais
toutefois cruciaux appelé fait urbain
que comme la ville elle-même sont
caractérisés par leur histoire et donc
par leur forme
qu'est ce qu'il y à de rossi il dit
quelque chose d'assez simple la ville
regardez la ville comme un artefact
quand quelque chose qui a été bâti par
des hommes pour des hommes avec une
forme très spécifique qui peut être
totalement mesurer scientifiquement
en gros chaque ville a sa propre forme
chaque ville est approchée d'une manière
extrêmement scientifique faisant recours
à la biométrie fargo la science à la
construction à la technique et en tant
qu'architecte il faut connaître cette
partie mais après la ville est aussi sa
propre identité et sa propre identité
est bâtie par ce qu'il appelle l'effet
urbain les fait rire bien son l'histoire
l'évolution sociologique sont tout ce
qui est arrivé qui dépasse cette forme
alors les architectes doivent se situer
sur pratiquement ces deux lignes
parallèles comprendre la forme de la
ville
comprendre son évolution son mouvement
et comprendre la société et prendre le
pari sur la société à venir
ça on le fait du coup à travers la forme
la forme est un mot qui en architecture
est utilisé partout
nous on prend la définition de paul klee
qui est assez extraordinaire
nulle part ni jamais la forme un
résultat acquis un parachèvement une
conclusion il faut l'envisager comme une
genèse comme un mouvement son être et le
devenir et la forme comme apparences
n'est qu'une maligne apparition là
forme n'est pas commun les choses nous
apparaissent mais la forme c'est le
potentiel qu'on arrive à donner aux
choses pour qu'elles arrivent à varier
avec le temps ça c'est le sens de tout
le projet le premier que je vous
montrais est un des logements sociaux à
bègles et nous ont été invités pour pour
ces trois lots à droite il y avait le
potentiel de construire 14 mille mètres
carrés on nous demandait des masses de
14 mille mètres carrés pour définir
l'espace public
c'est le principe de la ville
méditerranéenne ou de la ville
historique européenne c'est-à-dire les
bâtiments sont réellement ce qui fait la
rue sauf que c'était pendant la période
de la crise 2008 où les investisseurs
ont décidé de se retirer et du coup en
réalité on pouvait un construit de 14000
selon l'étude urbain mais en réalité on
nous a demandé que 7000 temps qu'on
avait cet espace gris qui est l espace
où on pouvait s'en douter quelque chose
où on pouvait peut-être tenté une forme
en mouvement et à l'époque on sue
questionné sur est ce qu'il existe un
modèle qui arrive à combiner les
qualités de la maison individuelle
c'est à dire pas avoir de voisins de
garder les quatre façades de chez soi
probablement un jardin beaucoup
d'espacés extérieurs avec ses du
logement collectif partager les
ressources se retrouver dans une
collectivité quand on en a envie et
surtout occupés moins de sol parce qu'il
est fondamental aujourd'hui de
sauvegarder du territoire et donc on en
date est une forme en superposant
pratiquement des maisons individuelles
ont occupé cinq mètres carrés en arrêt à
disposition d'autres 100 m² pour pouvoir
dans un futur proche
peut-être en faire quelque chose cette
idée abstraite est devenu ensuite une
proposition pour le concours auquel ont
participé
est ce qui était proposé en paix folle
parce qu'en fait le bâtiment faisait que
sept mètres de largeur chaque pièce est
très triple exposés sous la rue sous la
cour et surtout son propre jardin
d'hiver est donc triple exposé ça veut
dire trois façades
donc ça veut dire trois fois le prix
donc quelque part et le paradoxe était
là c'est à dire le lannou compacité du
bâtiment augmenter son prix et comme le
prix était très tendue du coup c'est
devenu un vrai défi on l'a fait à
dresser un principe très simple c'est
comme une ossature de parking sur lequel
on vient greffer finalement
six panneaux préfabriqués ça c'était une
image de concours 2015
l'idée étant qu en 2055 mais les gens
puissent occuper leur propre vide qu'il
est qui leur étaient vendus au moment de
la vente
donc on est finalement arrivé à ça et
tout s'est fait à travers des éléments
standardisés on n'a rien décidé sur
mesure c'est juste un assemblage
intelligent de deux pièces qui ont été
sélectionnés et acheter en grand nombre
les premiers occupants sont arrivés et
ce qui était assez beau et bleu j'ai eu
l'occasion de passer par la suite visité
le projet est effectivement il ya une
sorte de mouvement ici le mouvement
s'est donnée par le vide par le fait que
les gens puissent le jeune couple arrivé
là il construit dans ces grandes espaces
la chambre pour l'enfant ou quelqu'un
qui décide dit mathieu coussine il ya
véritablement une évolution qui est en
train de se mettre en place
aujourd'hui dans ce bâtiment mais il est
très rare en même temps qu'on a eu des
occasions comme celle de bègles c'est à
dire l'idée de pouvoir exploiter un vide
parce qu'on était autorisé à le bâtir
alors que nous maintenant se vident
porte tu m'as l'air économique donc pour
vous faire comprendre un deuxième
exemple totalement opposées du premier
j'ai sélectionné un projet qu'on a fait
à paris où chaque mètre carré du coa une
valeur énorme puisque la ville porte
cette valeur
c'est un projet qui se trouve dans le
dernier quartier qui a été construit qui
est le quartier des batignolles et c'est
un petit triangle qui à droite qui à
cheval entre le tissu ce manière et
cette ville à venir quand on nous
invitait au concours ça c'est l'image
qui était donné dans le rif c'est
représentatif de ce disque en train de
produire aujourd'hui en europe c'est une
architecture écologique une ville
écologique autour d'un pacte quand je
regarde cette image elle m'évoque tout
sauf paris et comme paris est ma ville
d'accueil et que du coup j'y suis
profondément attaché on a commencé à
réfléchir lambesc esquissé paris et
paris c'est quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire c'est l'exclusion d'un
tissu de manière continue à 27 mètres
presque un mono matière de la pierre de
taille avec des pièces chaque ornements
chaque fenêtre qui ont été finalement
acheté sur le catalogue entre 1850 et
1910 et vous le savez j'imagine mais
paris c'est la ville la plus dense
d'europe
paris c'est la cinquième ville la plus
dense au monde paris elle
même densité que shanghai est c'est une
montre suisse qui a été pensée et
construite pratiquement 60 ans passés
cinq personnes en particulier par
haussmann tout ça grâce à l' immeuble de
rapport
je sais pas si vous savez ce que c'est
un immeuble de rapport c'est un immeuble
qui rapporte de l'argent de l'argent
c'était la première forme d'immeubles en
location les familles construisez des
immeubles pour payer le crédit du
financement que la banque leur donner on
est en 1850
c'est le panorama parisien ben il a
quelque chose d'extraordinaire c'est que
1 100 ans en un siècle
il a été pensé pour être du logement
ensuite c'est devenu souvent des bureaux
pour redevenir des hôtels du logement du
logement social en tout cas il a une
forme de flexibilité et de résilience
extraordinaire dont canal a participé à
ce concours on s'est questionné sur est
ce qu'on nous sommes en mesure
d'apprendre de cet immeuble et le
transférer un clé contemporaine et ce
moment là nous avons commencé à
l'analyser il ya quelque chose d'assez
d'assez direct le la façade est faite
par 50% de vitrage et 50% de deux
parties pleines et ça c'était presque un
hasard puisque osman ne donnait pas de
règle à vérité participer aux ventes des
terrains en imposant à tous les
acheteurs et donc les propriétaires des
immeubles de rapport à venir qu'il
fallait aligner sa face à deux voisins
et qu'il fallait construire des fenêtres
rythmée comme leurs voisins
donc en gros on concevait les façades
sans savoir ce qu'il y avait derrière
puisque la façade est imposé à l'acte de
vente d'une certaine manière est donc
cette une façade générique qui permet
quelque part tous les usages si
l'auvergne séjour empreinte de fenêtre
dans une chambre on emprunte celle
ensuite les hauteurs sous plafond de
chaque étage après la lune de
socialisation de la construction des
gens comme moi qui se confronte un halo
différentes typologies en france quand
on fait du logement on met de m 82 dans
la dalle
quand on fait du bureau ont fait 3
mètres 62e dalle sur l'emprunt de faire
une galerie on met probablement cinq
mètres en tout cas il ya une relation
directe entre la construction
le volume et son usage qui est devenu
mécaniques donc on construit à travers
un système dimensionnelle ce qui est
assez étonnant dans un immeuble de
apport c'est que le rez de chaussée il
va de 4 à 6 mètres l'entresort il va de
2 mètres 83 m le premier étage quatre
mètres 50 et ensuite tu avais tu rentres
même temps de mettre 80 pour les combles
et pour les chambres de bonne à eau
il y as au sein de la même architecture
une offre volumes étiques extraordinaire
ce qui a permis dans le temps souvent
d'avoir des étudiants au premier étage
des bureaux deuxième étage en tout cas
une forme de vie extrêmement mixte au
sein de la même architecture
ensuite c'est un immeuble compact qui
s'est fait comme je vous ai dit par des
achats de pièces spécifiques sur
catalogue donc c'est une forme
d'immeubles hyper préfabriqués mais
surtout qui génère une identité forte
puisque on va tous achetés le même
garde-corps donc à un moment donné le
garde-corps devient la partie de l'adn
de la ville même et surtout il ya
quelque chose d'assez intéressant c'est
que le rez-de-chaussée peut se connecter
au premier étage à l'entresol sans
passer par la case commune d'escalier ça
ça veut dire que si demain mcdonald's
arrive il peut prendre le
rez-de-chaussée et l'entresol et si
c'est la petite boulangerie de quartier
à l'entresol quelqu'un va y habiter en
tout cas la réserve commercial de la
ville lp doublé et ça c'est quelque
chose qui rend toutes les rues à paris
extrêmement vivante si vous connaissez
paris vous savez que il ya des bars qui
ouvre chaque minute des restos qui se
transforme un club excédera une
véritable vie qui se fait à travers le
fait que la disponibilité de la surface
à vif lé p doublé donc ce qu'on a fait
de notre immeuble c'est qu'on a essayé
de reprendre ces cinq six
caractéristiques donc au tout départ on
a un très bel immeuble on a mis la
structure à l'extérieur pour rendre les
plateaux totalement flexible on a trimé
l'immeuble comme un immeuble de bureaux
à mes 35 pour que ça puisse s'exprimer
dans un bureau on a connecté le
rez-de-chaussée et au premier étage on a
utilisé un module entre étage de trois
mètres 20 qui est une cote mal taillée
entre logements et bureaux mais en tout
cas qui permet un bureau c'est un faux
plafond et un logement plus grand
on a utilisé une seule fenêtre quand
vous voulez des loggias b en plus la
même fenêtre et on l'a poussé en retrait
pour que demain elle puisse se remettre
sur la première façade et ça c'était au
concours b une version bureau une
version logement et on a chargé
évidemment toute la structure de
l'immeuble vos questions à mesure
2 accueillir des bureaux ou d'autres
usages donc on est passé des 180 kilos
au mètre carré pour les logements aux
300 kg des bureaux est plus que ça on a
radicalisé la chose en se disant que
tous les systèmes donc l'évacuation les
fils l'électricité en fait tout la
technique passé dans une façade
fabriqués de manière que ceux d'ici
demain quelqu'un a div
il sait que quoi qu'ils cherchent il a
juste à se mesurer à se connecter à
cette façade donc tous ces faits comme
un lego par des pièces préfabriquées
ce qui donne finalement cette
construction et ça c'est l'immeuble
et comme la parcelle était d'angle il
rentre automatiquement dans ce langage
iconique d immeuble d'angle parisien
dans ces deux exemples que je vous ai
montré on part toujours dans l'eure dans
un cas la forme le bouger à travers le
vide dans un deuxième elle elle bouge à
travers l'intelligence même de la
structure
mais dans les deux cas les immeubles
sont entendus âge quid si l'usager
réduit alors brancusi viser tous route
qui aurait une forme même mouvement moi
je dirai tout architecture est une forme
un mouvement et le troisième projet que
je vous montre parle de ça parle d'un
mouvement sans usage
le troisième projet du coup il est à
bure bure et ans après est très petit
village de la muse
ça ressemble à ça il ya 90 habitants bur
vous le voyez au nord bur un membre
probablement 120 et à sautron peut-être
200 et le concours c'était un pc c'etait
il faut faire le bâtiment qui consomme
le moins en europe et en même temps il
faut pas qu'il se voit il faut faire un
exemple qui ne se voit pas trop et il
voulait juste sur un étage
regardez l'histoire des archives vous ne
trouverez jamais un archives qui existe
sur un étage du conte s'élancer dans un
parcours pédagogique on a fait avec le
client dans lequel on expliquait que si
on faisait un cube de 2,5 niveau plutôt
que l'intérêt sa morphologie déjà par le
fait que la façade la façade inclut
aussi la toiture ben elle passait de
me fait passer de onze mille à cinq
mille pour la même surface mais déjà on
coupait la consommation énergétique par
deux parce qu'il fallait chauffer et
refroidir moitié de la surface et en
plus mais le fait de s'étendre sur la
parcelle fait qu' on ne s'approche de
plus en plus du seul point de vue ou qui
a de ce bâtiment qui est depuis la rue
alors que avec un bâtiment très très
compact et un peu plus loin même s'il
était cinq niveaux on aurait pu
finalement diminuer l'effet a trouvé
l'effet de perspective c'est lui demain
ça c'est totalement cliché mais des fois
il faut le faire par contre ce qui est
vrai dans cette histoire c'est qu'on
récupérer tout le terrain et que du coup
on pouvait gérer les eaux du bâtiment
les nettoyer et les réinjecter dans le
bâtiment à partir de là on était
convaincus qu'un cube était quelque
chose d'intéressant ce que je vous ai
pas dit c'est que une fois qu'on stocke
7h il libère deux fois l'année
quinze jours 10 et c'est un bâtiment
sans usage sait combien on stocke et on
repart donc c'est une sculpture au
milieu de la nature et l'alertent
occupation et l intégration donc à
partir de là on a commencé à réfléchir
sur comment intégrer avec les inputs
élèves et les films qui pouvait arriver
de ce qu'il y avait autour et tout le
monde y arriver avec la même image et on
s'était dit est ce qu'il est possible
que le bâtiment puisse changer de
couleur avec le changement de saison
être qu'il est possible que le bâtiment
puisse quelque part devenir blanc candy
à la neige ou réfléchir le coucher de
soleil ou en tout cas évoluer avec
finalement la seule chose qu'il y avait
autour qui était cet cette nature et
social et à partir de là on a fabriqué
des images qu'on a rendu au concours
dans lequel ont montré finalement une
matière issue de la terre une sorte de
béton de la même couleur que la terre
avec à l'intérieur des des points qui
étaient chromé et qui réfléchit c'est un
peu comme predator ce qui se passait
autour et on le montrait un blanc ont
montré un verre ou le matin de très
proche pour montrer qu'on se savait le
faire mais comme on était très jeune on
l'a gagnée on appelait le client et on a
dit on sait pas du tout comment faire
cette façade
et ça c'était une grande leçon parce que
du coup on a été très sonné à nous les
architectes vont nous demande de tout on
ne le doit qu'à moi je vais chez des
amis ils me disent vous êtes architecte
ouais j'ai une poule qui est cassé donc
il faut tout savoir et en fait on a pris
part ce bâtiment qu'il faut juste dire
que peut-être on sait pas donc à partir
de là on a démarré de recherche une
c'était le projet l'autre c'était la
façade
je vais vous montrer donc on a breveté
la façade et la main la manière dont se
construit et je vais vous montrer la
vidéo de comment on fabrique un panneau
donc ça c'est le moule dans lequel on
coule un panneau donc tout va avoir
l'air assez simple mais il faut savoir
que rien n'existait avant donc on a fait
50 millions de prototypes en main on a
cassé 12 millions de pastilles donc il
ya ces plastiques qu'on a on a fallu
trouver où on ne pouvait pas soudé donc
on a développé la colle le l'endroit est
indiquée par un une triangulation de
poing et une paire lionel sont collés
sur le moule
il ya quelque chose de kom kom petites
mains me 6,1 pastilles pour chaque
panneau nous avions d'ailleurs demandé
aux 90 personnes qui habitaient là le
village s'il voulait venir coller les
pastilles le béton est tentée de la
mince et on complète la figure à travers
du béton gris qui renforce la structure
ensuite il fallait bouger tout le sol
puisque le panneau était trop lourd
c'est le plus grand honneur aux 18
mètres de longueur suis trop m'en
voulait l'aspect de la terre finalement
on est venu sable et le béton à travers
un jet à haute pression plus du sable et
un lavage pour enlever finalement le
film et mais on a dû même développé des
outils le tout ce que vous voyez en
rouge c'est des outils qu'on est de
dessiner pour tourner ces panneaux qui
était chaque été pensé pour résister à
l'attraction
meba la rotation du coup tout cet effort
l'idée était de perdre l'échelle du
bâtiment et de faire qu'un bâtiment qui
n'a pas de fenêtre qui n'a pas d' usage
puisse en quelque sorte interagir avec
le paysage vous verrez 24 heures sur le
site et donc la course du soleil pendant
le printemps
il ya quelque chose d'assez intéressant
où cette forme finalement rentrer en
relation avec ce qui se passe autour
ça c'est juste une journée de 10h à 20h
en fait tout a été dessiné tout a été
pensé pour du jeu
à voir ces niveaux d'abstraction jusqu'à
la clôture qui est fait sur un système
anglais ou qui s'appelle à à l'idée
était de la faire disparaître
ça s'appellera parce que les gens
arrivent et finalement il tomber et là
il faisait 1 1
et du coup on voit pas la culture autour
cette abstraction qui fait que cette
forme devient une forme d'une pièce de
paysages on rentre à l'intérieur tout
est sous terre on retrouve un patio les
bureaux sont évidemment orienté
il donne sur la campagne ça c'est la
terrasse les cinq personnes qui
travaillent ici deux fois l'année
les archives en mms cas c'est beau c'est
qu'on avait on avait peur de la réaction
des gens
et c'était assez étonnant parce qu'à un
moment le paysagiste qui a travaillé
dessus qui s'appelle base et que du coup
de travailler à la fin du bâtiment m'a
appelé pour dire une bête il faut que tu
viens parce qu'il se passe quelque chose
d'assez intéressant
je suis allé voir du coup sur le site et
comme les gens non dans ces trois
villages autour n'ont pas grand chose à
faire et que finalement c'est le seul
endroit où un moment donné on paie par
reflets voir le coucher de soleil
ils viennent au bord de la route ils
mettent des petites chaises où il amène
le petit cousin où ils amènent leurs
enfants et ils utilisent le bâtiment
comme si c'était un belvédère et cette
histoire du coup et c'était un de nos
premières impressions donc c'était et 1
c'était vraiment touchant pour nous mais
ce qui me plaît c'est l'idée que
finalement le jeu vous parlez du
mouvement au départ mais je vous parlais
surtout de l'architecturé architecture
qui est ce moment où on ne répond pas
simplement une question mais surtout on
génère quelque chose qui puisse parler
même générer une histoire et je pense
que l'archivé df sort totalement
nucléaire sauf totalement du système
d'archivage et devient une pièce d'un
paysage que celui de la muse merci
[Applaudissements]